foreign
[Music]
next year action fans could look forward
to another adventure from the John Wick
Universe the previous John Wick movie
starring Keanu Reeves were a huge
success and are extremely popular now
the first spin-off ballerina is just
around the corner in our new original We
reveal all the latest details about the
plot the cast and the production stay
tuned
the previous John Wick movies were
mainly about the retired Hitman of the
same name who has to face off against
his former employer after his wife's
death ballerina is another chapter from
this world but not a continuation of the
main story the first spin-off centers on
a young female assassin on a quest for
revenge against her family's Killers the
connection of a ballet school with the
underworld was already shown in John
Wick 3 and is surely the origin of the
idea for the spin-off in fact the plot
of ballerina is set between John Wick 3
and John Wick 4 but so far the producers
have not revealed any more details
Anna De armas known from Blade Runner
2049 knives out or the Netflix hit the
gray man will take on the role of the
eponymous ballerina de armas already
demonstrated in the last James Bond
Adventure no time to die that she is
capable of action and is in no way
inferior to her male colleagues some
familiar faces from the John Wick movie
series will also be back Ian McShane as
Hotel owner Winston and Angelica Houston
as the Director have been confirmed to
reprise the roles also joining the cast
is The Walking Dead star Norman Reedus
who could be one of Anna De armas's
potential antagonists Lance Reddick will
also make a final appearance as
concierge Charon the actor passed away
unexpectedly this spring shortly after
wrapping up filming on ballerina
Keanu Reeves will return in his role of
the popular Hitman and will be part of
the cast of ballerina this is definitely
a good reason to celebrate according to
collider the Hollywood star was spotted
filming the movie in Prague last
November however it is not known to what
extent John Wick's role will be in
ballerina's new solo Adventure
for film distributor Lionsgate the John
Wick franchise is a total success the
last installment alone John Wick chapter
4 generated over 400 million dollars
worldwide on a budget of 90 million
dollars accordingly it comes as little
surprise that Lionsgate is also in
charge of the plan's spin-off Lynn
Wiseman is taking over the directing
duties his previous Works include the
underworld films with Kate Beckinsale
the reboot of Total Recall and the
fourth installment of the popular Die
Hard film series shooting took place in
Prague among other places and was a
challenging experience honored to armas
for example talked about the physically
demanding filming on The Tonight Show
with Jimmy Fallon quote I'm in pain my
body my back everything hurts I'm
complaining I'm sore I'm bruised Bond
was 15 minutes this is a whole movie
another level she also reported on a
rather difficult stunt scene with Keanu
Reeves and was very impressed with her
fellow actor he would deliver one crazy
performance after another so she could
hardly complain we can therefore
probably look forward to spectacular
action again including John Wick himself
the John Wick spin-off ballerina will be
released on June 7th 2024 until then
many fans are eagerly awaiting the first
impressions of the killer ballerina
story in sound and vision we can't wait
to bring you the first ballerina teaser
trailer what's your opinion are you
confident that the spin-off will match
the quality of the main series or are
you already done with a franchise and
don't expect much from further movies
and series from the John Wick Universe
share your thoughts with us in the
comments
thank you
[Music]